all right guys
bang bang i've got hong here with me
thank you so much for doing this
thank you for having me absolutely let's
jump into your background kind of give
us an
overview of what you did before you got
to okay coin
sure yeah look i'm not a early adopter
like many of your
other previous interviewees are when it
comes to bitcoin some of them probably
got into bitcoin
in early 2011 12 13 um
i got it a bit late uh although i heard
about it in 2013 or 12.
i didn't really quote unquote convert
until later in 2016.
uh but before i talk about that i'd like
to talk a little bit about my personal
background as well just to
share how i've grown up and how that
kind of shape up
my perspectives and and why i ultimately
converted
um so i was actually born in
in china i grew up in china in the in
the southern
part of china very a small town close to
shanghai
and i was born in a year when uh the
the market uh the free market concept
was
first introduced into china in 1979
anyone who was familiar with recent
history of china would probably know
that
that was the year when deng xiaoping
basically opened up the
the door and say okay it's not about
whether it's a planned economy a
communist star capitalist
it's about how we can uh help our people
to live better
right in that case it whether it's a a
black cat or
a white cat as long as the cat catches
the mouse it's good
so that was the year when actually you
started to see
market elements in a fully um
planned centrally planned economy and
that was when i was born so i would
actually had the luxury like everyone
else in my generation
to actually experience that transition
of economy
a huge economy from a 100 percent
uh centrally planned fashion into a
hybrid model
and i also had the luxury to experience
what it was like when it's
all all centrally planned because
initially when that policy was
introduced
you still had the the a lot of um
uh social stigma attached to
uh being an entrepreneur right now we
talk about entrepreneur like
it's great right you have
entrepreneurial spirit that's all you
really want to
strive for everyone is becoming an
entrepreneur but back then
if you are you became an entrepreneur
it's a social stigma it means that you
probably are not good enough
on your previous position you're a loser
um so there was a huge mentality shift
and also a huge
uh release of um productivity when um
free market was introduced and and
people individuals are given that
um freedom to choose to make decisions
on what they want to work on
what they think are fruitful and
actually um execute it
and you see a huge creativity in in that
sense and that's also why china has been
able to
enjoy a lot of huge growth exponential
growth over the last 40 years
it's all because of free market the
introduction of free market
and when when we see hurdles of that
recently you know there's some
growth slowed down from that perspective
there was also a lot of debate on
whether that's because you kind of get
to in in certain areas where
it's really hard to to further uh bring
that market
concept into certain areas of either
society or
economy so that was the larger
background of
where i you know how i grew up i had
that
kind of a personal uh first-hand
experience of how free market is
uh powerful um and then um i went to
beijing for my university for my college
education and
spent a couple of years there actually
nine years in beijing i went to picking
university
uh study economics and and language
in 2006 i decided to apply for an mba as
you know mba
stands for something that you can you
know basically after mba you can do
anything you want
kind of a myth um i decided to do that
because i want to be uh
you know more integrated into that
market first i think that economy and
capital market is really
what's really driving the innovation uh
in in the world and us
has the most sophisticated capital
market and has a lot of innovation going
on in silicon valley that was funded by
the capital
uh free capital structure so you know my
dream was kind of go to that
and be part of it um so back then i had
a different offers uh including chicago
and and walton
and and columbia i ultimately uh went to
chicago because again you know chicago
was a
school where there are multiple uh
professors having
got nobel prizes for economics right you
know uh
milton friedman eugene farmer stickler
and most recently taylor
for for his behavior economics and so
you know i
i went there i spent two years there and
graduated in 2008
i was a fantastic time to graduate from
business school
but i was lucky because i uh you know
had a
an offer back then in 2000 before 2008
uh crisis
hit you know all the lbo hit a all-time
high
and people all you know this this is a
new era
nothing nothing uh nothing we have
experienced before is
is going to be expected this time so
that was that that kind of
narrative so i got an offer from uh from
goldman
i i went to join goldman in the
investment banking division
so i had another choice back then uh
with goldman
either joining a financial institutions
group
fig or tmt uh for the investment
banking division and uh i made the
decision to go to
financial institutions again because i
feel like you know cap
money is is the invisible hand um that's
that's what i've learned from from my
business school from my finance
education money is the
invisible hand uh the free market um
there's a there's a lot of good things
happening but
everyone uh all our the whole world
is built on incentives right every one
of us we act on incentives
and a lot of those incentives some of
those incentives are probably not
not monetary many of them are and uh the
the money
monetary system the financial system
actually organizes and and
allocate resources um to the way that
the society needs
uh either appropriately or
disappropriate inappropriately
um so i think you know what you know tmt
sounds very interesting
but i really want to really understand
what's going on in the financial
institutions
in the capital markets and and probably
figures the right place to go so
i ended up in infect and spent
uh spent eight years um there more than
eight years with fake
um and uh now thinking back 2008 joining
fake was not too bad a choice
because 2008 was a year when uh even
before
i joined full time everything's starting
to uh
crumble down and after i joined i'm
sitting there
found and looking around and founding my
um associate in the first class
actually got got they got moved around
because of the
crisis some of them even were moved into
uh back office support
because of that but fig was kept busy
throughout that year because
only banks and insurance companies
particularly banks who actually need
money
they are doing a lot of work right
recapitalized getting tarp
raising blindfold all sorts of stuff so
luckily i was uh i was there in in the
middle of it you know seeing all the
drama happening uh seeing all the tarp
uh being handed out working on
blindfolds stuff like that
um um it was it was kind of interesting
because i was back then
still kind of in the learning mode i was
you know had no idea what's going on
i had no idea how banks operate how
insurance companies operate how
how asset managers operated so i was
really kind of duck my
head down and really learn uh and hope
that i i don't
didn't get fired just because of the
market volatility
um so i you know survived i ended up
working uh across
uh different different sub-sectors
within fig
serving all kind of customers for their
needs for
ipo for mna spinoff refi
hybrid all kinds of stuff and kind of
interesting
but there are also some aha moments
throughout throughout that process uh
one of it
which is you know uh when you're sitting
in the middle of the financial crisis
you see
all kinds of things going on you know i
was working with the client
uh raising capital and then in another
situation i work with investors
private equity investors trying to pull
blindfold together and buy those bad
bad assets but they actually were able
to secure
government uh sponsorship basically
government
guarantee that you know up certain
lost level government i'll eat it with
taxpayer money the rest of it
can take and we um reallocate uh
assets and put out a quote-unquote good
bank out there
so actually it turns out that you know
investing in those bad assets in 2009
10 and 11 were actually one of the best
investment time and investment uh
activity that appealed a financial
focused ap
or any type of pe investors can actually
look for
uh hope for um so that got me thinking
right because initially
the the whole crisis why it happened uh
there was huge
uh misallocation of resources huge
upside down
for the general public and i was even uh
worried if i went to a social
event i didn't really want to talk about
being at goldman because you know
in 2008 you don't really want to be part
of the government story
um but seriously you know thinking
thinking about that you know
got me to think about the resource
allocation what went wrong
and and also out coming out of that
financial crisis people who um don't
have enough financial resources
ended up having less financial resources
because you don't really get the
leverage to
invest in one of those first periods
only those with
a lot of financial resources excess
financial
capital they can actually they have the
luxury to invest and actually get
more return out of it um so that got me
to start thinking about
what's going on and what was wrong
um and then uh um
you know because i also have a different
experience working with
banks and insurance companies versus
with fintech companies i also got to see
how the different dynamics
when you work with fintech companies you
know the mindset is very different
trying to think look at the status quo
and think about what we can change to
really benefit the larger generation a
larger population
well uh you know the traditional
financial industry
is more about the status quo right and
the business model is very
straightforward
it's about capital allocation based on
the
where whatever the incentives are depend
on you know the current
system set up and so that got me to
think about
you know what i really want to do um uh
uh
when when i think about what you are
doing in the capital markets there is a
big
portion of uh resource allocation to
support the the high growth
uh the technology firms who are driving
growth through innovation there are also
a big portion of
resource allocation or asset
reallocation
you know people pursue mna spinoffs a
lot of those are
capital markets and removers that that
reallocate resources
but does it really create extra value
and also when you look at the price
movement market movement in u.s market
or even in global market you know take
chinese china for example
you see periods of asset bubbles
and when when those price uh really uh
deviate from fundamentals fundamental
doesn't really matter
anymore and at some point that that
music stops
uh and and you still think why why that
actually deviate
from from the fundamentals what's going
on because we all think about
market free market free market believers
say okay the price is the indicator of
the supply and demand right
and we don't have to know we don't need
a central planner who know
everything going on we just every one of
us just look at the price and price will
tell us
what i should do how i should allocate
resources so there must be something
wrong with that price indicator
that um lead to uh that
large scale misallocation of the for
social
resources um so uh fast track to 2016
uh i decided to uh shift because i you
know i want to actually be on the
investment side uh go get closer to that
the the innovation side i'm going
through
growth equity investment looking at uh
tech companies tech companies so i i was
uh asked by
a syrian entrepreneur in china he was
very famous and
and legendary one to to join him and and
help him uh
do uh uh with basically growth
investment
um so that was in late 2016.
um and that was it was because of that
shift that i uh got to know
uh star who was the founder of okay coin
he he started to uh
he started a quick point in 2013 as a um
uh r b uh uh crypto trading platform
uh primarily focused on chinese market
back then so between 13
and 16 it's all about chinese customers
trading in and out of crypto with rmb um
so i got to know about him and got to
know him and his
uh and the team and we seriously started
to talk about investment
um i was actually leading the series b
investment back then um so we were
talking about that and that was the oppo
at the time when i actually started to
look at bitcoin
uh in all seriousness i i heard about
bitcoin
actually in 2012. um one of my
md's a very senior uh lady uh a female
md actually talked to
us about bitcoin uh in a random meeting
we were talking about something else and
then she was like
you know what have you heard about
bitcoin it's actually a very interesting
uh
thesis and the value has been going up i
just slip my mind
if if i have time machine to go back
we'll probably change that but
uh like unluckily there was no time
machine
so uh in 2016 i was end of 2016 was
really when i started really seriously
look at bitcoin
and uh you know honestly uh back then in
uh
in 16 okay was doing really good um was
the number one uh trading platform in
china so it has a lot of users has a lot
of activity a lot of
volume and a lot of cash flow but that
was not the reason why i ended up
investing in them because when i look at
bitcoin and really debate on
what really it offers like if if there
was something that i learned from my
investment banking experience it was
that
really there are a lot of noises in the
market um you can
uh you know the market can deviate from
the fundamentals but long term it's
about the fundamentals
you know so give it some time and the
fundamentals will catch up so i was
asking myself
are there any fundamentals in this or is
it just all price speculation
uh that will you know fade at some point
and i was looking at bitcoin and i
i realized that actually this is
something i've never seen
before it's very new because it really
challenged a lot of the assumptions i
had
right uh some of the assumptions like
for example monetary
system i again i came to this us
because i believe in free market i think
this is the center of free market
um i went to chicago to because there's
a lot of
economists uh talking about uh free
market and kind of how you should
not tax you should you know do less tax
and give that power to
to people but in the traditional
economic economics and
the current the way that the central
banking was talking uh
about policies there was never a
question about whether
monetary system number one should should
or should not be
created or run by government and number
two there's uh there's never a question
about that assumption whether
inflation is a given uh we always talk
about
the the the base monetary policies that
you need to
have some you know two percent inflation
maybe
uh to encourage spending uh to to to to
produce growth
that was taken as a given uh
so those those are actually uh powerful
moments of kind of realization and say
okay actually
you know what that's probably that it
probably explains
why the price signals in market was not
working as well
because you've got a monetary policy
that actually intentionally inflates and
and it's really hard it's really hard to
um bifurcate that um from from what's
really going on
and and what we're seeing this year
exactly
uh show point that again um and uh you
know it's a replay of 2028
because arguably what happened in 2008
was a aftermath
of what greenspan has been doing with uh
with a monetary
policy in 2000 um so i think that was um
that was a big aha moment
um and that was when i was like okay you
know what this
there is a lot of uncertainty related to
this because you know when it comes to
monetary system
uh it's not just technology innovation
it's actually there's a lot of invested
uh interest
in this and and invested interest not
only by individuals but also by
various sovereign governments who knows
what will happen
um and you know something happened with
china uh policy
in 2017 related to crypto which kind of
speak to the volatility
in a volatility of this long term but uh
but but fundamentally i think it
shows that there it's possible to to
build a
uh rebuild a sound monetary policy that
is responsible that actually uh rewards
the savers um
and and and the the rewards those who
have longer term uh
time preference and it shows if you look
at chinese china versus u.s
economy right china has a much higher
saving rate versus u.s has a much
higher leverage we we all tout about
leverage
in the capital markets however if you
look at the growth rate
when when you have a higher saving rate
in the society you actually have
more capacity to invest for longer term
benefit
um so so i think that is really powerful
um
and the other powerful thing uh in in
bitcoin that i see
i was not just related to monetary
policy was also because it's it's part
part of it is um
technology that blockchain concept um
that you know very simply
designed and you can actually use those
simple things to
to effect uh large-scale um
interpersonal collaboration and enable
value
uh transition one-on-one
but it's also because the way it is set
up it actually allows
it use the combination of technology and
incentive
system to allow
[Music]
not not devilize
people who pursue their own individual
interests because i think
human beings are built to pursue their
own incentive it's just
part of us it's just inhuman to
to ask everyone to act in everyone
else's benefit
you know some of some of us can do that
but it's
unnatural to ask everyone to do it so
when you have a system that actually
reward
uh individuals who just pursue their own
benefit
and as a result of that actually build
the ecosystem and build a whole uh
platform
for everyone's benefit i think that's
marvelous i've never seen that before
um so that was again those are things
that kind of come together
and uh you know made my decision i made
my decision to invest in okay
so let me ask this question when you
made that decision
what were kind of the um the driving
factors right so it's kind of like
you bought into the idea of bitcoin you
found that interesting
um you saw value there but why okay
coins specifically
yeah i think um if if when when if i
believe in a potential of that future
uh it is a future where there there is a
combination of
uh blockchain technology and incentive
setup
that build uh on beyond
uh bitcoin bitcoin is the monetary layer
and the technology even
as it stands right now is still not
there but once the technology gets to
the next level or the the level beyond
it
um i think it should be we should we
would be able to see
a revolution even beyond that monetary
system
right um uh in the financial system as
we kind of are seeing right now in d5
but it's still very early stage it still
doesn't allow
large-scale uh uh high efficiency
transactions but
even beyond that i think the really
really what matters is that
real use cases like you know quick you
know ico
in 2017 there was a lot of white paper
floating around that doesn't really uh
have the
the substance supported but i think the
direction it was uh heading forward
was right um you know we just didn't
have the technology just to
really support and and uh and make it
happen but i believe in a
a world where you know ultimately
different parts of our economy right now
which was
run in on internet version right now
and through centralized platform
hopefully that can be realized in a more
decentralized fashion
through token so it would be a
combination of
that that uh underlying protocol
development
and incentive system built into it and
to be able to have that type of crypto
world
um taking effect and and function
smoothly
you actually have to have a priceless
gallery system
uh to for people to really see the
value of their crypto whatever that
crypto asset is
for right um maybe maybe pack it against
bitcoin in the future but you have to
have that
price discovery system so my thinking is
okay this is
definitely a long term right but no
matter what um
you'll need a a marketplace to discover
price
meaning a trading exchange uh and uh
okay coin seems to be
uh in a good position back then um and
and you know that's the place to go and
so that was really
why i made that decision yes there was a
lot of speculation but without
speculation without price increase you
it it would be hard to attract new um
new users into the space so it's just a
starting point yeah
absolutely makes complete sense talk a
little bit about
okay coin today um you know you guys
are based in the united states and kind
of have a whole bunch of different
features like when you describe the
business and the products to somebody
just give us an overview of what does
that really entail yeah
um so okay coin today we actually went
through
a lot of transitions uh you know as i
mentioned
uh back in 2016 15 16 17 we were
all um a chinese market
and the only trading pair we had back
then was just a chinese yen a chinese
yen versus crypto
uh in 17 we went through a a transition
because of the chinese government uh
shutting
shutting it down informally and not
allowing that that fiat crypto trade so
we actually
decided to come change our strategy and
come to the u.s
and other jurisdictions where there is a
clear regulatory framework where we can
actually
build out that vr element because we
believe that you know in the future it's
probably all 100 crypto
who knows that that's such a remote
future in very
uh a realistic way it's probably a
parallel right parallel world where we
you have
crypto but you also have um traditional
fiat stuff
so we need a bridge um between the two
we need
to give people easy access uh into
crypto or out of crypto
and that's what we are trying to do uh
okay coin to provide that easy on-ramp
offering access to crypto and
and also drive adoption i think crypto
even today
you know with with all the uh excitement
that we are seeing and defy
over the last three months it's still a
very small population thing uh it's you
know
it's very hard for people to general
public to to
to grasp the concept of private key and
you know access and set up node um
not even everyone within crypto can
actually do that so i think i think
there's still a high part across but
um getting more people to really
understand to start off to understand
what bitcoin is about and
and see if they actually agree with the
fundamental uh principles that bitcoin
is proposing
and then maybe going beyond that you
know what are the other
potential uh uh protocols and crypto
assets that they identify with
either want to invest in or utilize in
the future i think that's
really what we think about ourselves uh
our mission is kind of on that adoption
direction i want to make it easy for the
general public to do that
um that's why you know for now we have
been in
a building mode because to be that
bridge
like it or not you have to be compliant
and getting getting licenses in u.s in
the right way takes time um so we took
we're taking time to do that over the
last uh uh three years
um and uh over the last year we've been
also
you know with with license application
kind of uh
more than halfway done we started to
also invest in
uh areas where your product and
marketing growth
um and kind of drop try to build that
infrastructure and and get some of the
uh good products out there to
supermarkets um
you know we have been updating our
current product as
is to to make it easy adding adding a
adding instant deposit and making easy
flow but there is a lot more that we
want to do with our product so
so we'll continue to do that yeah yeah
that's awesome
i read somewhere uh and something i
found very interesting is that you're
actually
helping to fund bitcoin development as
well talk a little bit about
um where did that come from and kind of
what's the thought process behind it
sounds like you guys are basically have
money going out
but uh not necessarily directly money
coming back in and or more just
supporting developers building on
bitcoin
yes yeah uh i think that circles back to
how we see bitcoin as part of the crypto
uh world and also my uh uh experience
from
from uh goldman um again you know going
back to
the fact that you know uh when we look
at what's going on
out there either in traditional space or
in crypto you know we went through the
ico process right um that the bomb
and burst um and we are right now in a
d5 wave
uh you know there's a lot of debate on
whether this defy is the same with
ico where it's different but coming down
to i think uh what really matters for
crypto to
to uh be long-term successful and
actually
uh deliver what we believe in in the
first place is
about the fundamentals are we building
the protocol
in the right way um obviously and again
when i think about crypto there are two
elements one is that underlying protocol
level and the other is the
incentive that's built into it uh
obviously bitcoin is already
is the most uh mature crypto asset
in crypto and the way the incentive
system is built is very clear
very simple and it's it's built in the
in the sense that it was
um meant to be by being that digital
gold
being that kind of monetary layer but
there's a lot of stuff that need to be
done
to the protocol to make sure that it
actually is secured it's
it's uh it protects privacy it can
scale to the to the best it can so i
think there's a lot of work that need to
be done
there and you know we um as an exchange
we don't necessarily
um get direct benefit from uh sponsoring
those uh
developers but we think it's important
for us to do that because
uh bitcoin is the fundamental layer of
our industry so if anything
bad happens to it you know we are all
gone um and uh i would we would like to
be able to sponsor
uh sponsored the continuous development
and we're we don't think we are the only
one right and and it's
it's good that we're not the only one
and we don't we didn't uh we don't
want to be the only one and we don't
want our form of
donation to be the only form of donation
i think it's actually good
to have different uh parties jumping in
actually after our efforts so we also
see a lot of our
health in the exchange industry to jump
in and also
provide support which is great which is
what we would love to see
um and we started with bitcoin again is
because
it is the one of the oldest developer
community it doesn't really have
a central um a central
uh uh sponsoring uh entity right
um and it's very much community driven
uh it's unlike ethereum for example you
know there's a lot of
different organizations sponsoring it uh
bitcoin is really uh
out there on its own and um i think it
takes every efforts from
every one of us to to to uh to support
its uh continuous growth
so that's really why and we'll uh we'll
continue to do it uh but ultimately i
think it's really kind of
uh investing in in that protocol and
also
uh see uh to to to whatever extent we
can
um try to be that bridge to uh
between developer community which is a
more fundamental
uh community and the more niches also
more specialized community to the the
general investor
and general public help people
understand what's going on there
why they're working on what they're
working on what matters to us and things
like that we also
learn a lot in that process as well um
and we'll continue to
do that how do you see the kind of
landscape of exchanges both in the us
and internationally
um kind of unfolding right there's um
kind of
a whole host of different exchanges they
all have different strategies you guys
have kind of a very unique
um you know type strategy you spend a
lot of time building recently
how do you think of like differentiation
and kind of like where you want to
um kind of find success like what is
that thing that you guys say hey we want
to be known for x
yeah uh i don't want to speak for other
exchanges i think again
as you mentioned there are a lot of
players out there some
some are around uh longer somewhere
around shorter uh obviously most
recently we have
eunice swap which is a totally different
animal and we're very happy to see them
grow and and the volume outpacing
coinbase but
again from our perspective uh our focus
is really on
uh promoting adoption and we want to do
whatever we can to do that
and that means that we have to focus our
resources on that
keep make it simple make it make it easy
for people to get in and get out
is that does that mean it has to be
centralized exchange or whatever format
that we want to take maybe but but it
can also be
you know uh connecting to the d5 world
uh in some sense
um so we're exploring we're you know uh
doing that uh internal debate and and
some of it will translate into product
and some of it probably will not
after internal discussion uh but
hopefully we're
all moving in that direction and which
is you know we wanna
we wanna help uh promote adoption uh
help people come more people come in and
understand and embrace it in whatever
you know format
because not all you know some of us are
die hard
bitcoin holders we just buy and hold we
don't trade some of our
uh daily traders right coming in the day
out
you know bitcoin word altcoin doesn't
matter
and then there's some other people who
are not really um
familiar with it and they're still
debating what it would be and how
they should manage it i think from our
perspective
and me as a kind of a long-term wall
street
practitioner i think everyone should
take a very responsible approach um
not diving before you have actually have
some uh
idea of what's going on and and and also
particularly if you don't know what's
going on you don't have full conviction
don't all in just put a small amount
into it and then see how it goes
uh that's probably or just get you know
one bitcoin for your
children and just leave it there so
one of the interesting things to me is
like part of the bitcoin narrative of
store value is
to hold bitcoin right obviously
exchanges want as much trading as
possible because that's how they make
money
how do you kind of think through the
balance between uh maybe that bitcoin
ethos of holding and store value with
kind of the business goals of lots of
transactions right
that's a very kind of interesting thing
and i think you guys have a unique
perspective on
yeah again as a from a business like
from personal likes perspective
i obviously have my personal preference
when it comes to whole versus
trade and i respect that for everyone i
think everyone has
has that and should make that choice and
that's also what makes
uh make will make it successful for
bitcoin long term like if
all people are trading and not holding
then
you know it's problematic because you
all end up having speculations
but if uh no one is trading everyone is
holding then there is no liquidity and
and uh
there's no price fluctuation and no uh
interest
from from the uh non-crypto community so
i think it's actually healthy to have
uh you know both and uh as an exchange
from a business perspective we're not
going to dictate on
you know whether you should hold or
whether you should trade it's all
individual choice again you know back to
how i grow up i really believe in that
uh uh empowering individuals i think
um if you look at um if you look at the
evolution of the internet right
over the last 10 or 20 years last 20
years in u.s last 10 years in in china
i think there is a very clear trend of
democratization
of everything starting from message
starting from e-commerce trading buying
and sell
and then gradually getting into uh media
more
more uh more sensitive areas of media
but you know the the recent
uh tick tock was making a big splash
here
one of the big reason we i i actually
invested in tiktok when i was doing my
growth investment
which you know hopefully it looks like
it's a good one um but one of the reason
that they were successful is because
it was really giving that
right to users it's all user generated
content
it's not that platform trying to
essentially produce it it's whatever
user want to do you produce it and you
know you
see how much interest you're generating
locally um so i think that uh
democratization
is very powerful and um
what we are doing crypto is i think is
in line with that the ultimate thing is
really to empower
individuals right um and uh crypto
hopefully with with the right incentives
and and we
we do need as an industry we do need
more technology
advancement more advancement in the
protocol level uh to be able to host
uh um more use cases real real use use
cases and
and to be honest you know i i spend all
my
professional life in financial
institutions uh and i love what's going
on
with c5 but but i think ultimately what
will make us successful as is as an
industry for crypto
is you we have to see more use cases
outside financial industry
uh that's when things will really take
off uh
and you know yeah look forward to that
absolutely and so when you think about
that future world where you know
things have taken off go out maybe 10 or
20 years like paint a picture of
what is the kind of holy grail situation
or kind of where
where are we headed if you will uh ten
years
ten i don't know what happens in ten
years we'll see um uh
but you know uh ten
ten years is a long uh it's a long
horizon
if we think about what happens in ten
years uh over the last 10 years
in in us in china you know things have
totally turned upside down um but maybe
maybe crypto will bring even more
drastic change
changes to us uh maybe not um
there there are a lot of hurdles to that
too right uh there is the
um advancement at the protocol level um
there there's regulatory uh framework
how how that will shake out
because even in the internet space or
where you see
more innovations that actually benefit
society benefit people is when actually
regulators taking a seat back and see
what's going on
before jumping in and say this is not
right
and that's not right um you actually
give them some space to experiment and
see
what works first is what doesn't work so
it's hard to tell
um i'm i'm generally positive
uh but you know it's hard to there
there are some pieces of it that that's
kind of uh hard to predict
as well so i i would say that long term
i'm very positive
um but there is uh natural
volatility because of that that i think
we should expect and we should embrace
as an industry and work out
work through it um ideally in a
in a ideal situation i think we are
we would i don't know if that happens in
10 years or so but
i think in an ideal situation there's no
company format uh there's probably no
government format
it's our community and you know each
community
based on each protocol with its own
token is almost like a
country uh that we have right now but
again that's uh
that's a you know i don't know if it's a
remote
reality let's see absolutely and then
what about
okay coin 10 or 20 years from now like
what is that kind of north star
or where are you driving the
organization and want to see it get over
the next kind of decade or so
again i don't know uh 10 years it's
really hard to tell
uh right now what what we currently have
is
i think the the way we see the evolution
is that there is a
there is a long uh period of
uh transition time or uh a period
where the two worlds ran in parallel
right
there may be situations where the tools
collides
um you know we'll put that possibility
aside first
but there will be a long time when the
two worlds
coexist together so we want to be for ok
coin in its current form and we want to
be that connection point between the two
uh that the format of that connection
point can change
as the industry changes you know uh we
are
as you know uh much better than anybody
else you know
our industry changes every minute um
so it's hard to tell you know our
internally we
we look at things every two months and
that's probably feeling too
still too long um so it's really hard to
tell
uh how how things will look like ten
years but but i think that north star of
uh
promoting adoption is going to be
important for us to
uh to mobilize around
yeah look i think that uh just the
perspective you have is uh it's so
balanced and um i think
this idea of like hey we're building a
business but we believe in the ethos of
bitcoin and a lot that's going on there
and the willingness to
uh support bitcoin developers and kind
of really be thoughtful about
what you're building and kind of how you
roll it out and stuff is uh it's pretty
impressive to see
before we uh we wrap up i ask everybody
the same
two questions and then you'll get the
opportunity to ask me one
uh the first one is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
uh i like foundation
trilogy awesome why do you like that
um i read it a very early
age um and i think it was eye-opening
it's a combination
of uh sociology and you know the
the way they talk about psycho history
you know
on one side it reflects almost reflects
what happened with roman
empire but on the other side it
um it shows the possibility that um
you know human being human society uh
individually it's very hard to predict
but if you look at it on a over a long
enough horizon and a larger
enough scale you can probably see some
patents
and use that to predict things it's
different from
central bankers trying to predict
monetary
policy i think and there's a lot of uh
interesting moments where you see
small small characters in this story
actually
shaping history but not shaping history
changing it because
it kind of diverted from that path
it still follows so math uh matters
actually
there there are some uh sacred uh
uh rules embedded in that number game
so i think that's really interesting um
yeah i i
i love it i love that answer that's
awesome
um aliens is the second question are you
a believer
or a non-believer
i i i i think it's
unlikely that we are the only planet
with uh
with life i thought you were gonna say
it's unlikely that aliens existed i was
gonna be shocked
but okay unlikely that we are alone
makes more sense
it's unlikely we just don't know uh
where they are or maybe
they are but we you know we are not
aware of it maybe we are in their
program
whatever um so yes i i i think it is
uh we just don't know yeah i i tend to
agree with you and
uh based on 2020 i started to think that
maybe we are actually in a simulation
right
yeah it's like somebody is saying uh
hey you guys dealt with that pandemic
thing okay here's a tornado here's a
hurricane
like deal with murder hornets right they
come with all kinds of crazy stuff
yeah um you could ask me one question to
wrap up what's the one question you have
for me
uh look you have talked to so many
people uh
you know you said 400 podcasts uh
everyone
bring in different perspectives um are
there any
things that surprise you uh that is kind
of
almost like a common theme that you're
seeing again and again
um um despite kind of what kind of
background they're coming from
yeah i don't know if there's things
necessary that surprised me i guess the
the biggest surprise
and uh this is somewhat of a joke but uh
there's only ever been two people who
came on the podcast and said they
believed in ghosts
more than they believed in aliens that
was a little surprising
but but in terms of like the actual
content around like business and things
the things that are maybe uh less
obvious
are the really simple things right so
everyone who listens is always waiting
for somebody to come on and have you
know you
say hey if you want to build a
successful exchange here's the secret
right or like here's the magic bullet
magic bullet of course right because the
the operators understand there is no
magic bullet right it's it's building a
business right so you've got to build a
product you've got to make sure that
it's what people want you've got to
scale it you've got to market it you've
got to hire people you've got to manage
people like
it's all the blocking and tackling of
building a company and i think that
um that's probably the the thing that it
doesn't matter
what industry doesn't matter what stage
of the business like
the blocking and tackling of building
and or funding companies
uh is exactly what you think right it's
hard work
um and there is no magic bullet there is
no kind of
oh hong walk up this morning she you
know typed in the uh the secret code and
now all of a sudden okay coin is
successful
like as much as we want yeah as much as
we want that to be the answer that's
just not how the world works
and so i think that um that's probably
the thing i've taken away the most
is uh everyone if they can
kind of realize the people who came
before me and have been successful
did the same things that i have to do
and people who come after me are going
to do the same things there is no
shortcut
um i think it just focuses people like
okay let's go do the work right and so
that would kind of be my answer
that's very good thank you thank you for
sharing that absolutely
where can uh we send people to find
either you on the internet or find out
more about ok
coin um i um obviously uh i'm on twitter
i'm not
super active to be honest because i'm
still uh
focused on a lot of the internal stuff
but you can find me on twitter
my twitter handle is a hp ca
i've been using that for a long time uh
obviously we have our
website you can visit okcoin.com and uh
we also have our uh
okay coin twitter as well please uh come
and
interact with us and give us your
feedback
awesome well listen hong i really
appreciate you taking the time to do
this i know you're super busy
but i think people will really
appreciate just hearing your perspective
and kind of
um the vision that you have for not only
the company but also where uh where all
this is going
um and again it's really cool to kind of
see the the approach that you guys have
taken in terms of
funding bitcoin development and kind of
you know really taking the time to build
stuff
uh i'm pretty impressed so uh thank you
so much for uh for your time we'll have
to do it again in the future
yeah looking forward to that thank you
palm thank you for your time